foreign
[Music]
Thanksgiving is a time for appreciation
it's a time to remember our many
blessings
celebrate with the ones that we love the
most
and for all families to be together
[Music]
[Applause]
let's see
there's something wrong with the school
something doesn't feel right
so if you what happened
that there's something here
that's not meant to be
[Applause]
what are you doing
she's standing
this thing it's come back for me
this demon was once an angel
rejected by
God's power
it wants that power back
it's okay to be scared
I'm scared too you
and bad thing back to hell
[Music]
who is it it's nothing oh dude it's Pete
oh my gosh that is pretty funny
you're in Salem they didn't teach us all
our history
some stories got lost along the way
maybe if they had taught us everything
that happened my brother would have left
that knife where he found it
I will play I won't quit
you know what I think we should do right
now go to the party come on let's go
if you play with me then I'll let you go
to your party and I won't call Mom okay
Joe what game do you want to play
[Music]
camera you'll all say I will play I
won't quit
tell me demon
am I it
morgas
what did you do let's play
Marcus
how are you ready to play hide and seek
Marcus why do you have that knife bye
why are you doing this
go what is going on it's not him it's
the knife
found you
hey buddy you're just messing with us
right how about something
it only ends when it wins
what if we win only one way to find out
I will play
now
let's play a new game
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-pronged treatment
outside Mexico City the results have
been stunning she saved my life
you're in very good hands with us
after that what happens then your whole
life happened John Kramer
according to these scans the tumor was
never removed how much time do I have
months at best
I still have a lot of work that needs to
be done
[Music]
this is
hello everyone it's time to play a game
you all pretended to cure me but what I
have planned for each of you is very
real
[Music]
only thing I have not provided is your
anesthetic but trust me
you will want to remain alert
[Music]
of all the men to cheat you picked John
Kramer please don't hesitate place a big
enough piece of yours or you grow tissue
into the glass enzyme tank this will
save your life
thank you
this is not retribution it's a
Reawakening
[Music]
the choice is yours
thank you
I have a job for you
cake really
[Music]
good
it's a security gig
hello
welcome to Fred
them yeah
meant who
foxy Bonnie Chica Freddy
back in the 80s
some kids went missing what is this why
the place shut down
we searched Freddy's okay they never
found the kids
[Music]
thank you
ghost children
possessing giant robots
tell me how to stop them
you don't it's too late
he's coming
[Music]
foreign
don't be scared
we've met before
are you looking for Reagan are you
looking
forward
[Music]
what do you think evil is
laughs
I'll tell you what I think it is
we're born in this world with Hope and
Dreams
and a desire to be happy
it's happening to my daughter too
the devil has one wish Wherever those
girls went they brought something back
with him
I believe you can help get her daughters
back to kill it in us and the devil
never gives up
she knows who I am
where's the other girl
[Music]
what you're doing here is
people have died on both sides of
possession
come on baby
what is it baby
I'm right here I don't wanna go to hell
they're two heartbeats isn't working
they're beating in sync
be strong
what did you do
one girl lives one girl dies
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
ER
on Charter from Romania to London
shipping private crates
content unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
serious kind of
image dress like a learned man
University of Cambridge I know my way
around the boat our Charter has agreed
to pay a bonus for timely arrival in
London
is huckleberry
we don't come with like this to give
this clear
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
powerful evil
all right
[Music]
in night it drinks our blood
we call him Dracula
the world is a man he's coming
you see the size of that Bloody things
[Music]
the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
right
Alice engaging with trolls is like the
worst possible use of your energy
[Music]
since you joined BuzzFeed your art got
super lame and you die in a fire
don't judge me sometimes you gotta troll
the trolls
[Music]
oh
foreign
belongs to you really think a weird
account is haunting your apartment
here David he was only 10 and his mother
went insane
is your son and you put him in a coma
Dr Landers
[Music]
oh my God
you see my son David I'm having you what
does he want ask him yourself
[Music]
I've found something
I've looked at it from Every Which Way I
Am the smartest person I ever met and I
can't figure it out so I came to the
second you are up to something my friend
I've seen a million these so-called
psychics each one of fake
I do not believe in psychics come with
me to a seance spot the con I can't
detector you are here to discredit me
but I can talk to the dead I give all I
have to hear I chose his voice if
someone wants to be heard
we are here listening
um
Felicia
what is happening
[Music]
[Applause]
you can't trap is here somebody is dead
no one should leave this place until I
know who did it a ghost killed her
there must be a rational answer for all
of this just admit that you are up
against something bigger than you no
you were saying
something in this house tried to kill me
don't look at me like I'm suspect we're
old friends
every mother has somebody's old friends
no one shall leave until I find if the
living have been killed by the Dead
you have been hiding here all this time
who are you talking to
countless reports of arson and vandalism
a state of emergency as violence reaches
historic levels go knock them dead and
then revive them again and just keep
like an endless loop you're gonna be
riding with Jason 15 years on the job
but you do a lot worse
a little stabbing of one male party 412
Broadway okay here we go let's move okay
all right he kills the cob
drops the car here if it's a body in the
front seat who does that
[Music]
oh man
some type of accelerator this was
intentional
come on
these are messages bro
[Applause]
what we deserve
[Music]
Tamira what's going on with you all the
stories we are going up they're all true
it lives inside
foreign
[Music]
laughs
you know when I was a kid
I used to want to rip that moon right
out of the sky
but life doesn't work that way
does it
I know you want to be an adult
but it's different for us
Sunday someone's gonna come along
and accept you for who you are
you're not going anywhere you know that
right I'll be back before midnight so
I wonder what would scare you what do
you mean
I wonder if what I want with scale
what do you want
[Music]
I can't just be who I am
it's okay
[Music]
look at this family
let's pretend that we're going somewhere
really really far away from here
[Music]
foreign
I heard it again
no more nightmares tonight okay champ
[Music]
this is getting ridiculous
this is an old house
there's bound to be bumps in the night
Peter Drew this yes is he all right
Peter has an overactive imagination
[Music]
nightmares no more that's right
you know I wish I had someone I could
talk to about the things that were
happening in my house Mom
[Music]
[Applause]
mom
[Music]
Peter sometimes
you have to make hard decisions to
protect your family
what is that
the banging
[Music]
you don't hear anything Peter
imagining it's going to get you into
trouble one day
[Music]
the lord of the night mates with a
non-vampire woman she will give birth to
a dumper
baby I need some time alone
I've always had nightmares now they see
more and more real
like Memories trying to re-emerge
the words of the night killed those like
you at Birth you're way too dangerous
now Gorka knows you exist he'll do
anything to exterminate you can you take
me to ask bring him here to my
slaughterhouse
what exactly are you careful
[Music]
does it feel to know where your life is
coming to an end
[Music]
it's going to be a long War
welcome to the world of nightmare
Soldier Boy
Harper has his first new zombie movie
coming out in over 30 years no one knows
anything about it except it'll Premiere
here exclusively in carverville
Halloween night
is the projector ready
[Music]
anything else no start the movie
what is this
you just roll the film and it turns the
actors into the Living Dead
power to suck the souls out of everyone
in this vicinity we can stop them from
spreading as Marion had all the
knowledge if he were here he'd know what
to do your films must be burnt you have
to destroy them all go to the theater
stop the projector that's the last film
no freaking way
I just got my driver's license you drive
[Applause]
get away from it
[Music]
hit him on the head
we're in really big trouble we'll never
watch another zombie movie again
hurry up
[Music]
your mom's gonna be very upset with you
I love your costume which right oh it's
not a costume I was sweeping the floor
okay fine one month detention please
[Music]